pilar take it away teach us how to cook
our pasta a matrixyana out of the
essentials of italian cooking
by marcella harzan and page 157
we want you to cook with us so you at
home
who are kind enough to be watching us
please submit photos
videos anything you got to join us in
this culinary venture all right lynn
daniel zenobia feel free to ask
questions
while we go pilar take it away all right
so we're doing the matritiana sauce and
one of the reasons why i love this this
pasta is because it's super simple
and it has pancetta in it and it uses
bucatini pasta which is one of my
favorite favorite pasta shapes
it's like a spaghetti sexy cousin you
know it's like bouncy i like it
all right so first we're going to do
you're going to add two tablespoons of
oil yup
right there yeah looks so clear yep it
is a vegetable oil
ah and we're gonna do one tablespoon of
butter
and over here we have one medium
onion does it matter what uh what type
of onion you use could it be like red or
dahlia so i think that um
for this recipe they use a yellow which
is kind of the standard workhorse onion
vidalias could be used but those are a
little sweeter
white onions as well but i am actually a
shallot fiend
and if you are looking to substitute a
different kind of onion i feel like give
shallots a go
for sure i love it so the onions now are
getting sort of pale and golden
and now we're going to add in our
pancetta
so basically pancetta is uncured um
pork belly and we're just gonna saute
that for about a minute to let
the flavors meld with the onions zenobia
you had a question
for pilar yes i do um
can the panchayat be uh substituted for
uh regular bacon will it take away from
the
rest yes so that's a really good
question um so
things like guanciale and pancetta are
actually
cured pork products where they're not
smoked whereas bacon
is a smoked product so just be mindful
that when you're using that the bacon's
actually going to be less salty
but it's going to give it that smoky
flavor
and now we're going to add in our one
and a half cups
of um chopped canned tomatoes
we're going to give that thank you a
question about the sauce
yes so when you add the tomato sauce
sometimes i find that i simmer it too
far down
is it okay to add some more of that
tomato sauce
absolutely so what i like to do when you
drain off a can of tomatoes is actually
reserve the liquid
until you're finished cooking because
sometimes it might reduce too much
and you can always add more later so
definitely keep the sauce until you're
done cooking so that you make sure
all your bases are covered fresh
tomatoes
um so you you can they're gonna take a
little longer
to cook down and what i would recommend
is if you're gonna use fresh tomatoes
really use them at the height of their
season um
that way they're going to be extra extra
delicious because do you want seeds or d
seed i don't mind a seed i feel like
deseeding in the kind of sauce like this
is going to get
a little more fussy and it's not
necessary but you can use plum tomatoes
you can use marzano tomatoes
fresh like in season just know that it's
going to cook down a little longer
so we have this beautiful sauce over
here and i added some chili flakes
red chili flakes to taste and then
basically you have that sauce going for
about
25 minutes just simmering on low are we
switching let's ready one two
three yeah well there we go oh beautiful
yes so we have this beautiful sauce it's
been reducing
and now comes the fun part we're going
to toss in our buccatini
into the sauce
right into the sauce right on my thighs
it's true let's let's see why the
puccatini versus a different type of
pasta
good question so the sauce is actually
from a region specifically or a place in
italy
where buccatini is their traditional one
of their traditional shapes
it also has this hole in the middle of
it
so it sops up even more sauce which is
really really nice
but you can use any long shape that you
like
spaghetti would work really nicely as
well all right last thing we're going to
add to this beautiful sauce
here we go we're going to do three
tablespoons
of parmigiano-reggiano parmigiano
and two tablespoons of pecorino
and you're gonna give that a good mix
oh parmigiano and then the pecorino yeah
so it's two cheeses
which is really exciting for me
are we ready to play it i was just gonna
say i got the ladle out
all right so i am plated up here how are
you doing drew i
am very excited because i think
everybody here knows that this show is
an entire ruse
for me to eat my face off and you can
finish it with a little more cheese
as you wish okay so i'm going to grate
some more just over the top all right do
we get to try it now i sure hope so
oh my gosh you guys again i feel do we
get to try it
i know i feel bad i feel horrible i'm
like
you guys want to watch us eat this
delicious food all right
next time this is our first cookbook
club i'm thinking next time
we'll make sure that you have those
dishes in front of you because
now i i feel guilty it looks so good
all right ready i'm just going to tell
you it's horrible
[Laughter]
thank you guys for joining us
see you next time exactly
[Applause]
i want to thank um everybody for joining
us and i want to make a special
announcement
that cookbook club is something that's
really meaningful
um and it's about building a community
and we want to donate
five thousand dollars to um the monday
night hospitality
at the all souls church here in
manhattan which is very near beautiful
and dear to my heart it's a place i've
spent time
actually my daughter has also
delivered food there on holidays and
we're going to continue to find places
such as that that provides food to
people
in these meaningful ways so i just want
to thank everyone for joining us today
for cookbook club lynn daniel zenobia
you guys are so awesome thank you guys
thank you for kicking off our very first
cookbook club
and obviously um chef pilar
you